ich hab dre Jahre Fußball gespielt
langdo nein ehlichlich hallo K grüß Dich
Tön guten Tag Tag das ist der Kameramann
der Mann da hinter der Kamera der Mann
in Schwarz ja wir drehen ja nicht mit
versteckter Kamera offen find ich
gut am
Strand ja das ist Porz übrigens ne so
wohne ich ja schon länger also nicht
hier keine Badehose dabei aber im rein
schwimmen ist auch gefährlich aber die
Wasserqualität ist ja immer besser
geworden let das ist
richtig was für ein Bild
herrlich darf ich dir was zu trinken was
möchtest du ger also wir haben holunda
apfelschle li Wasser Kräuter ich fang
mit Wasser an wenn es geht aber gerne
thank you
so bitchön danke sehr so prust ja
prust wir haben gefühlte 40° würde ich
sagen schön kalt wir sind gut
vorbereitet das finde ich sehr schön wie
ist ansonsten die Lage die Lage ist
ernst aber nicht hoffnungslos nee ist
schön ich habe noch ein bisschen lange
hingebraucht deswegen war ja ein paar
Minuten zu spät Stau wie immer aber
sonst alles super Stau Köln instadt wird
immer gebaut Köln gleich Stau
Ausrufezeichen ja spätestens seit die
U-Bahn gebaut wird wobei das war jetzt
severensbrück habe ich gehört genau das
war sens die wird alle 20 Jahre neu
gestrichen und das ist jetzt der Fall
und wenn wir werden ja den sag mal die
Eröffnung der U-Bahnstrecke auch nicht
mehr erleben wir zwei das wird J 2078
sein und da bin ich leider schon tot
oder 107 kann auch sein das heißt wenn
man in Köln lebt muss man eigentlich
komedien komediant kabartist
werdenbalist ne muss man muss man gar
nicht es gibt ja auch Leute die
vernünftige Berufe haben
ich habe keine Ahnung das Glück gehabt
irgendwann da mal den den den das Hobby
zum Beruf zu machen und habe dann 1991
angefangen
auf die Bühne zu gehen und das hat ganz
gut funktioniert und jetzt darf ich
sogar im Fernsehen auftreten also es bis
jetzt kann ich mich nicht beschweren gut
das heißt aber vielleicht doch in Köln
gibt so viel Material da kann man das
gut werden ich glaube in Köln reden
Leute eh viel und man wird einfach
angequatscht also gerade auf dem Weg hin
da habe ich noch ein paar Leute
getroffen man wird in Köln einfach
angelabert und alles gut
und das ist z.B in anderen Städten nicht
so in München habe ich mich selber dabei
erwischt meine Frau hat in München
gewohnt wir sind damals dann
gependelt dass ich in der Straße wo
meine Frau damals gewohnt hat ich
dieselben Leute öfter mal gesehen habe
und irgendwann habe ich einfach mal
Guten Tag gesagt oder grüß Gott sogar in
Landessprache und die haben m angegucken
gesagt was will der Blonde Spinner die
haben gar nicht geantwortet in Köln ist
das normal und da wird halt ein bisschen
unnützes Zeug geredet aber man spricht
von daher vielleicht eine ganz gute
Voraussetzung für für die Bühne aber na
ja ob jetzt in könln alle lustig sind
weiß ich nicht ich hatte das Glück
damals über den Karneval auf auf die
Bühne zu kommen da war aber diese
Standup Comedy noch nicht so oder gab's
noch gar nicht so ja diese Szene und das
ist heute einfacher für Leute zu sagen
ja es gibt offene Bühnen da kann man
hingehen sagen ich bin lustig probiere
mich aus und ich habe das dann damals im
Karneval gemacht super jetzt hast du
auch mir wurde gesagt ein oder zwei
Fragen darf ich dazu stellen ein ganz
neues Kapitel aufgeschlagen in deinem
Leben sieht man auf deiner Webseite paul
ist geboren und zwar vor ganz kurzer
Zeit genau ja wie ist das so du der paul
ist ein cooler Typ muss ich w schön es
gibt ja wie bei in so Wohngemeinschaft
von Studenten wir haben neuen
Mitbewohner jetzt ist ganz spannend und
ja das ist ein neuer Lebensabschnitt
allein die vor Zeit vorher in der
Schwangerschaft macht man sich natürlich
Gedanken wie könnte das sein aber wenn
so ein Kind da ist das ist
ich glaube man wird reifer binnen kurzer
Zeit und
eine große Verantwortung man wird da die
nächsten Jahrzehnte zusammen verbringen
als Sponsor werde ich dann mit meiner
Frau fungieren hoffe dass er das auch
ein bisschen zu schätzen weiß
ja und mal gucken wie sich so ein Kind
entwickelt also es ist ja schon glaube
ich das ist auch so ein für mich ein
Sinn des Lebens dass man vielleicht
seine Gene oder so ein paar
Einstellungen weitergibt und ja mal
gucken ob der Paul wie der sich so
verhält was für ein kleines Kind da bei
einem groß wird mal sehen okay gut ich
habe jetzt eine Frage
ne nein ich will die kommt später die
komm später jetzt will ich was anderes
fragen was ich daraus ergibt warst du da
gut drauf vorbereitet weil ich habe
gehört du hast ja früher im por warst du
auch als Babysitter unterwegs nee das
ist Quatsch habe ich noch nie gemacht ne
ich kenne Mutter die sagt du hätest bei
ihr Baby ges ich kenne auch Leute die
viel erzählen was ich alles schon
gemacht habe die mir auch erzählen wir
haben uns doch da und da du hast do das
und das mal sage ich dreimal nein die
sagen doch ja und irgendwann beim
vierten Mal sagt man dann um Ruhe zu
haben stimmt okay also g du kennst me
war meinem Sohn auf der Schule erzählen
mir Leute der heißt so und so sagt nee
der war nicht bei mir in der Stufe ich
habe auch ein Ports Abi gemacht in in
waren dann sagen die doch aber und und
nach fünft mal sag ich ach das ist so
ein großer blonder nee so ein kleiner
dunkler ach ja genau so also als Babys
habe ich noch nie gearbeitet gut okay
aber das heißt du bist hier in porortz
bekannt wie ein bunter Hund und jeder
kennt dich auch wenn er dich nicht kennt
ja na ja gut also ich meine ich bin hier
geboren ja damals war das ja noch
eigenständig 1971 Ports am Rhein hieß
das damals dann wurden wir 1975 ja von
Köln übernommen das war eine große
Schmach allgemeine Gebietsreform der
Porz an sich hatte da nichts gegen sehr
schade wobei man sieht wie toll das ja
hier ist am nicht Langel Lido wie wir
sagen sitzt der
Guido ja und porort hat 100 im Moment
glaub ich 108000 Einwohner ich bin hier
zur Schule gegangen wohn seitdem hier
finde das sehr angenehm und ja in Ports
sagt man auch das ist doch der unser
Guido aber du stehst schon hinter por du
findest por ein super Städtchen oder ich
find das hier kann man super Leben hier
ist das sehr dörflich nette Menschen und
gut die Innenstadt ist jetzt so vom
einkaufsflare ein bisschen begrenzt ich
habe ja immer mal den den Satz geprägt
bei uns kann man super Einkaufen wir
haben immerhin ein Handyladen eine
Bäckerei noch eine Bäckerei noch ein
Handyladen und ein Mobilfunkladen und
Backshop und noch eine Bäckerei und ein
Handyladen und egal ob du ein Brötchen
kaufst oder ein geklautes Handy die
sagen immer es ist noch warm und das ist
glaube ich die halbe Wahrheit ja ne es
ist wirklich hälich wir haben ja so ein
riesen Kaufhaus muss man auch außen
stehen man sagen dass da mitten drauf
steht da konnte man auch mal was kaufen
aber das ist vorbei das ist jetzt nur
noch ein Betonklotz also es ist schon
hässlich eigentlich die Innenstadt ja
aber die Randgebiete sind klasse
traumhaft also ichich hat es nie
woanders hingezogen oder hast du mal
überlegt zwischendurch also ich bin
jemand der gerne im Urlaub ist ich bin
auch gerne weg ich bin beruflich super
viel unterwegs aber so ein Nest zu haben
und eine Heimat ist mir persönlich sehr
wichtig ja und die Leute die so meine
Freunde sind die kenne ich auch schon
lange das ist jetzt nicht so dass man
nur noch mit Leuten unterwegs ist die
Promis sind und im Fernsehen rumton da
kenne ich viele da gibt's auch einige
nette aber richtige Freunde sind die die
ich schon lange kenne und deswegen muss
man gar nicht wo anders hinziehen ist
das auch so ein wirklicher Grund weil
man kennt es ja bei vielen Prominenten
in dem Moment wo du prominent bist
kannst du ja gar nicht mehr
unterscheiden befreundet der sich mit
mir weil der mit dem Promi befreundet
sein will oder findet er mich selbst ist
mir total wurscht also ist wur das also
bei manchen Leuten wo wo mir persönlich
das nicht so wichtig ist ist mir das
egal wenn ja ich bin freundlich und nett
zu Leuten wenn man ausgenutzt werden
sollte muss man das den Menschen
natürlich mitteilen aber
sonst ja ich weiß ja wer meine Familie
meine Freunde die kenne ich und alles
weitere ja ist schön viele Bekannte hat
man natürlich okay ja aber du hast ja
selber erzählt die Leute in
Anführungszeichen schmeißen sich so ein
bisschen an dich ran gerne ne wir ach
das ist doch immer so ich meine wenn ich
jemand kennenlerne nehme an ich lerne
ein Fußball Nationalspieler kennen da
kenne ich auch ein paar mit den ich
schon öfter mal gekickt habe dann finde
ich das auch toll ja weil die kenne ich
auch aus dem Fernsehen im Thema Fußball
jetzt bin ich großer Fan und wenn ich
mit permertes Aker Bier trinke fin ich
das auch toll ja ja und das ist glaube
ich normal es passiert mir ja auch dass
man Leute bei Veranstaltung sieht
Schauspieler und die grüßt obwohl man
die eigentlich gar nicht kennt aber man
die natürlich aus dem Fernsehen kennt
und die mich aus dem Fernsehen kennen
dann Größen die zurück und dann kommt
man viel schneller ins Gespräch aber de
facto hatte ich vor mit Heiner
Lauterbach auch noch nicht so viel zu
tun wir haben es letztens aber gesehen
getroffen und dachten glaube ich beide
wir kennen uns aber i kannt euch gar
nicht vom sehen vielleicht aus dem
Fernseher aus der kisteustig hast du
dich schon mit jemand oder ist es dir
schon mal passiert dass du dich dann
doch angefreundet hast dass eine
Sympathie entsteht oder ist die Distanz
im Mediengeschäft zu groß nein so jemand
wie Hugo Egon Balder ist natürlich super
Typ dem ich auch viel zu verdanken habe
weil ich 2003 als genial daneben losging
da mal mitmachen durfte hugesagt Mensch
den finde ich witzig den probieren wir
aus und daraus wurden dann sechs oder
7ben Jahre glaube ich wo ich regelmäßig
und und oft dabei war total cooler Typ
der trotz seiner gefühlten 130 Jahre ich
glaube hugo ist um die 60 m coole
Klamotten anhat sehr jugendlich im Kopf
ist super Musiker ist und mit dem man
einfach Blödsinn machen kann und das
finde ich äußerst angenehm und man sieht
sich dann aber zu privat auch mal und
schreibt sich mal SMS und telefoniert
aber ist auch nicht schlimm dass man
sich dann nur ein paar Mal im Jahr sieht
und das ist toll wenn man sich sieht
freut man sich und da gibt's einige in
der Branche die die wirklich klasse sind
die entspannten ja schließ ich da draus
ich finde immer und das ist meine
Erfahrung dass in jeder Branche die
wirklich guten
Leute total einfach sind und
problemlos das das sieht man auch in
Unternehmen also Vorstände oder
Vorstandsvorsitzende sind meistens total
locker weil die haben es auch geschafft
die so Riege in der Mitte die noch
Erfolg haben wollen sind öfters mal ein
bisschen anstrengend und
unaufgeräumt wie bist du ich glaube dass
ich sehr geerdet bin
ähm ja aber das können andere Leute
immer besser beutn ich glaube ich stehe
mit den mit beiden Füßen auf dem Boden
und weiß dass ich einen tollen Job habe
der mir Spaß macht aber ich weiß auch
dass das in paar Jahren relativ schnell
vorbei sein kann das muss man wissen
einfach immer war das immer so oder
gab's Zeiten also als ich das erste Mal
gesehen habe ich weiß gar nicht mit
welcher Sendung dass du ins Fernsehen
geschwappt bist dachte ich echt ein
Karnevalist im Fernsehen da habe ich
aber wer ist denn schon mal Moderator
von der karwalsbühne geworden na ja ob
das man gut geht weil es halt was ganz
anderes ist du hast plötzlich die Kamera
zwischen dir in dem Publikum das ist ein
total anderer Umgang auf der Bühne musst
du große Bewegung machen vor der Kamera
musst du kleine machen weil sonst
fliegen die Leute v Fernseher weg also
so Kleinigkeiten sind schon gab's da so
Momente wo du nicht entspannt warst und
sagt ich muss mich jetzt anstrengen um
das zu schaffen oder war das immer so
entweder klappt oder klappt nicht oder
ja gottag bin ich nicht dieses DSDS
Phänomen dass man innerhalb von zwei
Monaten gehyped wird die ganze Nation
einen kennt aber nach di Wochen Fragen
die Leute wer war denn das noch ich kann
für mich beanspruchen dass das alles
Schritt für Schritt gegangen ist ich
habe 1993 mein ersten fernsehftritt
gehabt dann ging das so 98 99 los hat
ich Exklusivvertrag bei ATL damals und
habe da so bei die ersten comod die
Versuche
gemacht 2001 eigene Sendung bei RTL 2
die ist tvtv das war so ein so ein
Abklatsch so ein bisschen von von Stefan
Rab für mich damals eine tolle Erfahrung
da durfte ich dann Fernsehen machen ich
war der Host also der Gastgeber dieser
Sendung da hat man auch viel gelernt das
war schon wichtig und dann wie gesagt
2003 ging dann genial daneben los habe
ich einiges bei Kabel 1 gemacht und das
war immer so Schritt für Schritt und
deswegen bin ich froh es war nie so dass
man direkt nach oben katapultiert wurde
Zwischenzeit hat man sich jetzt
vielleicht auch mal gewünscht dass es
ein bisschen schneller geht aber ich
kann sagen dass ich glaube in dem Laden
oder in dem in dem Genre noch länger zu
überleben und hoffe auch dass ich noch
in 10 Jahren Fernsehen mache und wenn
nicht dann ist auch nicht schlimm der
das ist einfach ein Lernprozess Bühne
ist toll und ich glaube dass man da so
viel lernt was man einfach bei einer
liveesendung verstehen sie Spaß gut
gebrauchen kann weil da hocken auch 2000
Zuschauer und dieses ja dieses
Mittelding zwischen groß für die für den
Saal arbeiten und aber auch für die
Kamera für die Leute zu Hause kann man
lernen aber ich glaube auch dass eine
gewisse Veranlagung und Talent da auch
von Nöten istm gibt dir die Ruhe dass du
immer sagen kannst ja und wenn es im
Fernsehen nicht klappt kann ich noch
ewig weil man kann ja wirklich im
könlner Karneval kann man ja im Prinzip
ewig auf man kann das ist genau wie bei
J von der Lippe Jürgen von der Lippe
macht immer Tournee das ich habe mehrere
Standbeine und der jürgen hat immer
gesagt ich mach zu Tournee und
bühnenaftritten Fernsehen aber Tournee
wird immer mein Hauptstandbein bleiben
und bei mir sind es mehrere Standbeine
bei mir ist das Tournee geworden ich
habe Tournee ma ich er se glaube ich
knapp vier Jahren habe nie Tournee
gemacht weil das brauchte ich nicht hat
immer genug zu tun bin auch in so Sachen
ein bisschen faul bis dann mein
Management irgwann mal gesagt hat so
kannst wir haben
Hallen gebucht und jetzt im Herbst geht
die tnee los schreib mal Programm dann
habe ich mich mit einem Freund
zusammengesetzt hab Programm geschrieben
dass er siß ganz schön frech und das war
als ich das zum ersten Mal gemacht habe
ich gesagt du bist ja ein Vollhorst dass
du Tonen nicht schon früher angefangen
hast weil das super ist man die Leute
kommen natürlich wegen einem dahin man
kann sich austoben man kann Klavier
spielen man kann singen machen was man
will und großartig das mache ich jetzt
erst seit 4 Jahren das ist immer noch im
Aufbau macht super Spaß das werde ich
auch noch länger machen dann gibt's
Karneval da mache ich viele Moderationen
für Firmen Firmenveranstaltung und dann
gibt's eben noch Fernsehen und wenn eben
Fernsehen irgendwann nicht mehr klappen
sollte dann gibt's noch genug andere
Standbeine also da habe ich gar keine
Angst gut das gibt dir eine gewisse Ruhe
absolut klar das war auch im Grund bei
verstehen sie Spaß ganz entspannt
anzufangen oder wie war das als so der
erste Anruf
kam also ich kenne dieses Format schon
länger 2005 weil ich selber als
Lockvogel da einiges gemacht habe und
war auch schon in der Sendung live
Auftritte gehabt und Frank Elsen hat
damals gesagt pass mal auf vielleicht
ist das ganz gut dass du hier bist
vielleicht wird da ja mal was draus das
war ganz am Anfang konnte er auch nicht
wissen aber hörte sich ja ganz gut an
übrigens ein ganz toller Kollege Frank
elzner kann ich nur sagen kann man den
Hut
vorziehen hat also sich mir gegenüber
super Verhalten und hat mir viele Tipps
gegeben kann man sagen
chapeot ja und dann habe ich irgendwann
vor zwei Jahren mal gesagt eigentlich
wäre das genau das Format was ich gerne
machen würde also es geht um Humor da
kenne ich mich mit aus und moderieren
das ma ich auch gerne und die
Kombination wäre doch genau richtig habe
natürlich nicht entfernt daran geglaubt
dass ich das mal machen werde und als
dann der Unterhaltungschef vom SWR
gesagt her kann ich komme nach Köln
machen machen mal ein Termin zusammen
und dann gesagt hat ja was was würde sie
denn auszeichnen oder was was glauben
sie warum man sie nehmen muss als
Moderator für verstehen sie Spaß habe
ich gesagt na ja ich bin spontan ich
arbeite gerne live ich kann moderieren
ich kenne mich mit Humor aus und ich
kenne das Format also ich traue mir das
zu und dann hat er gesagt ja was spricht
D dagegen dass sie das machen und sagt
na ja dass ich für die öffentlich
rechtlichen speziell für die
noch nicht so viel gemacht habe ich habe
viel für Sat1 gearbeitet und na ja
sicherlich Irin Kritiker sagt na ja da
ein Comedy Typ da und so ein Karnevals
Fritze da ob der eine Samstagabend
Sendung um
Uhr moderieren
kann ich habe gesagt ich glaube ich kann
das dann hat der gesagt okay wir machen
uns mal Gedanken und in zwei Wochen
hören sie von
unswann kam der Anruf das sieht ganz gut
aus und glaub noch eine Woche später kam
der Anruf sie machen das was ist das
eigentlich für was ist das für ein
Gefühl wenn man in so einer großen Halle
moderiert und wirklich eben es ist ja
eben live Sendung vom Millionen Publikum
es ist live es ist von millionenpikum
und noch vor 1usenden in der Halle ich
find's super kein Flattern nein ich bin
jemand ich tret lieber vor 2000 auf als
vor 20 ja das ist schwerer wenn man das
gewohnt ist also es für mich ja keine
neue Situation wenn man nur im Studio
immer gestanden hat und kommt dann raus
und hat so ein Berg Leute vor sich ist
man vielleicht erschlagen von dieser
Masse nee das finde ich gut trotzdem ist
man natürlich nervös also vor der ersten
Sendung
klar war ich da sehr aufgeregt dazu kam
noch wir hatten einen Brennpunkt vor uns
weil ein Flugzeug abgestürzt ist in
Polen nicht unbedingt ein Thema was so
locker in verstehen sie Spaß übergeht
nicht unbedingt Moderation machen am Tag
vorher kam noch raus dass Kurt Felix
wieder an Krebs erkrankt ist auch blöde
Sachen und diese anspang habe ich
natürlich auch gemerkt wobei ich sagen
kann ich war super zufrieden mit der
ersten Sendung ich habe das handwerklich
fehlerfrei nach Hause gebracht natürlich
ist da viel Spielraum nach oben da
brauch man sich gar nicht drum
unterhalten aber auch Thomas gottchalk
und gün auch oder Harald Schmidt waren
bei ihrer ersten großen ähm
Samstagabendshow garantiert noch nicht
so souverän und
ähm ja locker wie sie das heute sind das
kann auch gar nicht sein da muss man
auch mit der Aufgabe wachsen und bei der
zweiten freue ich mich jetzt schon seit
längerer Zeit sehr sehr das zu machen
weil na ja jetzt man weiß wie es geht ja
man hat das mal einmal hinter sich
gebracht und ich habe jetzt schon Lust
das öfter zu machen also es kribbelt ja
klar super das ist schon gut sehr schön
dann wünsche ich dass es noch lange
kribbelt ja ja ich hoffe auch dass nicht
der Herzinfarkt ist der irgendwann im
Arm zu spüren ist oder so nee soll in
Fingern Krippeln genau gut vielen Dank
danke
schön